[Music]
nice yeah really PC my name is Brett
azhagi and I'm a postdoctoral researcher
and we're here to study the Pittman's
you compare it to other soils peat is
really carbon decks it's made up of
partially decomposed plant material all
the carbon that the plant accumulates is
life it doesn't fully break down so that
carbon stays in the ground unless you
were to disturb that ecosystem then that
carbon will very likely be released into
the atmosphere and that will contribute
to rising greenhouse gas levels and
climate change
peatlands only covering 3 percent of the
Earth's land surface but they account
for more than a third of the carbon
stock I mean I think that what we have
here in the Congo is the largest
tropical peoplein complex in the world
this morning we're going to head off
into the forest we're hoping it will
actually reach start of the peatlands ok
previously we've produced our first
estimate of how much carbon these people
in the store and I were onto a kind of
second phase where we're trying to
improve our mock with the people's taint
we'll stay dry today see if I can make
it
I think there's almost no hope it's
happened it's too late nice we know this
is pizzas
it's organic Brian material that starts
at the stake if it was not Pete so be
with a gray color we're gonna clog it up
and that gets taken back to the lab to
work out the density and carbon
concentration I'm really relieved it
wasn't actually sure if we would find
pee underneath this around the world
peoples are undergoing quite high levels
of degradation and destruction for the
sake of oil palm plantations rice
projects my fear is that something is
financially more lucrative than
protecting the peatlands will mean that
these peoples will be sacrificed for
that my hope though is that the data we
produce will give the people the
information they need to make better
informed decisions about how to manage
the Osito systems
[Music]